Wow that exhibit opens to the public on
Friday and that's a moment that God
everybody was fine walking through
because we were marveling it really was
a great trip down memory lane but when
Oprah hears from people directly the
impact that she has on them that
instantly is a game changer for her and
just this morning guys in the car the
guy who is driving me this morning his
name is Aida he's from Pakistan he said
he came here in 1992 because he heard
that we were talking about Oprah
he was started watching The Oprah
Winfrey Show and he would see her walk
in the aisle with the audience and some
of the issues she would cover she would
cover and he said I just knew that she
was a good human I'm so sorry because
I'm so used to talking about her but
it's a way that he said it this morning
and when I say all the things that are
in this room it is getting to me and at
the bottom line she really is a human
who just wants to do good in the world
and this exhibit is a testament to that
I have to say special shout out to a me
blind gloom who's Oprah's chief of staff
who I know this isn't the kind of thing
that Oprah would have ever done for
herself and Amy just stayed on it stayed
on it bugging or bugging her that points
when Oprah would say just leave it alone
I don't want to do it no no no no
thank you Amy why moon for that and the
staff here Rhea and Kathleen who put
this thing together and I didn't even
call it a thing it's beyond amazing what
has happened in this room
and Gail everyone's so sorry no I'm so
glad you share it with us Gail because
you say oh I know but Oprah was gonna go
down the other day and view it by
herself and you said no no no let me
come down and do it with you let me take
a camera that was so brilliant because
Gail yeah well it was it was Ryan
Carol's idea so thank you Ryan but I've
been there from the beginning until so
to see it like this I am full and I'm so
proud there's nobody like her and you've
got to come see it it opens on Friday
you see it